hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to people
there's nothing wrong with getting in
touch with your feminine side unless
you're a guy in which case that makes
you a but everybody has at least
one movie that they've cried it and for
the most part they were shown to us when
we were little kids for crying out loud
there's no doubt about it
kids films had some of the saddest and
most depressing scenes in cinema history
for films that were supposed to be
family friendly there's a lot of
emotionally tormenting stuff and we were
shown in our childhoods which is why
today I am bringing you the top 11
saddest movie moments from our
childhoods why top 11 because I like to
go one step beyond so women get out your
tissues men prepare your sleeves this is
the top 11 saddest nostalgic moments
[Music]
number one saying goodbye from Muppets
Take Manhattan
you wouldn't think the Muppets would
ever be able to get you teary-eyed but
at the scene where they all had to go
their separate ways it's pretty damn
depressing see why is it sad makes us
remember the good times we've had out of
all the Muppet songs ever sung this is
by far the saddest making us feel bad
for a bunch of talking socks for crying
out loud that's the sign of good story
comments when the movie has you feeling
emotionally attached to an amphibian and
a horn get ready for lift acquittal in 3
2 1
number 10 the Bluebird song from Follow
That Bird this takes place after Big
Bird is captured by tooth carny folk who
want to parade him around as a service
attractions the guy's masquerade him
offense the Bluebird of happiness oh boy
Bluebird of happiness that sounds
uplifting Bluebird that's been dreaming
[Music]
to that familiar place to be
back
sunny days I mean geez this is pretty
damn depressing for a Sesame Street
movie all that's missing is for a single
tear to fall down Big Bird's eye
oh that's just too much if you're not
crying by the end of this Bluebird song
get your eyes checked number nine
death of littlefoot's mother from The
Land Before Time let's face it dinosaurs
are always going to be cool but who
would have thought you could actually
feel sorry for you
the Land Before Time had a lot of
depressing moments but the saddest one
of all is when little floats and mother
fights off the evil Tyrannosaurus Rex
and sacrifices her life in the process
do you remember
[Music]
even if you can't see me Oh for crying
out loud
how can a movie make me feel bad for
something that died eons ago not fair
number eight an American tale just just
an American tale everything about this
movie is depressing I surprised
everybody didn't get depression just
from watching it the story is about a
little mouse who gets separated from his
family while moving to America
the family thinks he's dead but the
mouse continues to look for them anyway
and the rest of the movie is a
tease he thinks he hears his father's
violin but it's just a record player he
thinks a mother mites can help him out
but they don't have him out at all he
thinks he found his family's house
[Music]
and on top of that every other second he
walks right past his family as they just
barely miss each other just turn your
head to the left dammit
[Music]
damn it just get together
thank God this film was directed by Don
Bluth the same guy who dragged a gland
before time his philosophy was that
children can handle just about anything
as long as you attach a headband
you mr. Bluth
I may be able to take it but my therapy
bills won't number so the ending of
what's opera doc this is considered one
of the best cartoon shorts of all time
it was epic
beautiful and of course funny as hell it
was summarizing all the vogner operas in
both music and scope but takes a real
surprising turn at the end with Elmer
Fudd the god of lightning here tries to
strike down Bugs Bunny with all his
lightning bolts
[Applause]
oh boy what to give me like all crispy
and black or something
[Music]
in an opera a happy ending number six
the going-away party from Snoopy come
home it's not like Charlie Brown was a
very upbeat cartoon to begin with so the
idea of doing a whole section of the
movie that was meant to make you feel
sad is just downright cruel the scene
involves Snoopy as he decides to leave
home and go live with his original owner
so the kids decide to throw him a
going-away party a joyful charming
heartwarming go anywhere
[Music]
and that's not bad no Charlie Brown
sings about what it's like to say
goodbye right after this scene just when
you think that you know where you stand
see
[Music]
you know what I need I need more hellos
what is up with these people that
supposed to entertain our kids not
depress the out of them number five
the drowning of our Tech's from the
neverending story this is one of the
cleverest fantasy movies that ever came
out the 80s but with all its imagination
and creative characters it's the death
of a horse that we all remember
apparently they're going through the
swamp of sadness where only those who
let the sadness and depression get the
best of them sink into the swamp
thank God Steven Wright doesn't go there
but wait a minute the horse artex starts
sinking well what the hell does that
mean the horse has depression what the
hell do you have to be depressed about
thank you sorry Wilbur I just don't
think my mother ever walked me just find
out my business went bankrupt my
girlfriend just left me took all the
oats and I lost my sister to the glue
factory
yeah wife's a bitch and then you sink
sorry Wilbur yeah like I said makes no
sense number four the death of
Charlotte from Charlotte's Web okay so
maybe all spiders don't look quite as
cute and lovable as Charlotte did but
that doesn't mean we weren't all
affected when she spent the last few
days of her life helping out a damn Pig
it wouldn't be so bad except she talks
about her death like she's going out to
the store I'm done for Wilbur in a while
I would be dead oh well I guess that's
cool and as if that wasn't bad enough
she actually sings a song before she
died oh you'd think oh now that's the
sign of a true hardworking entertainer
working behind the scenes never taking
the credit and leaving out a song what a
showman a show spider Charlotte
I'll never use a can of rain again
number three the funeral scene from
Michael after the success of home alone
Macaulay Culkin was America's hottest
child actor which is why it's so
shocking that any movie let alone kids
film had the balls to actually kill him
all this girl has a lot of grief to live
with not only is her only friend in the
entire world dead but she's the one that
knocked down the Beehive that caused him
to get stung to death it's because of
her moving that Culkin went back her dad
is the Undertaker of Culkin's body the
funeral is held at her house and she
finds out that the teacher she had a
crush on is getting married on the exact
same day she and I are gonna be married
this I don't know what medicine
they gave her to stop her from turning
into a psychopath number two
the death of Spock from Star Trek 2 okay
I know this is a bit of a stretch but
hey a lot of kids did watch Star Trek
back then and even if they didn't we all
knew who mr. Spock was the pointy eared
guy so when we saw him sacrifice his
life for the team you can rest assured
every Vulcan was crying green tears that
day everyone
Jasper rock on man the idea of killing
off a main character in the Star Trek
movie was unpredictable but the idea of
killing off mr. Spock
the most popular character on the show
that was just insane I mean
nobody saw that coming
now granted a lot of us know that he
comes back and the following sequels but
we didn't know that at the time we
thought he was really dead
especially one Kirk makes his big handy
speech at the end of all the souls I
have encountered in my travels his was
temples
marketable human
I'll bet - and to top it all off Scottie
plays Amazing Grace on the bagpipes no
less this is so corny and yet somehow so
freaking sad Oh
my deadhead comeback in Star Trek and
the number one sense nostalgic moment is
every single God did a Disney movie ever
made I mean what the hell is wrong with
this company in every other film someone
dies someone leaves someone's in a deep
depression I thought this was supposed
to be Disney the happiest place on earth
happy like a bullet like remember this
happy moment how about this picker-upper
let's not forget this cheerful memory
Disney is always associated with family
entertainment child-friendly fun but I
think they hold the record for the most
crying scenes than any other studio
[Music]
Oh God I think the saddest moments are
probably the death of cymbals father the
kids of Old Yeller
and of course this scene is so famous
that people still talk about it even to
this day in fact there's a famous
Animaniacs episode that satirize this
emotional and crippling sea actually the
funny thing is
have you watched this scene recently I
mean okay you got the mother shot that
came looking for her and the father
saying your mother can't be with you
anymore but watch what comes immediately
after can you imagine they did that with
all their Disney films
[Music]
sorry guys it isn't that simple when
somebody dies birds and flowers don't
always pop up to make everything better
you have to deal with it like everyone
else in this cruel depressing
kid-friendly
world I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't
[Music]